who is
since you're one of the biggest
podcasters in the rp movement space
um red pill is just basically seeing the
world as how it is
and it's it's basically like the way
they describe it is blue pill is like
the lies you've been told by society and
like feminism okay and you take the red
pill and you see the world for how it is
okay okay okay okay
interesting so it's like the matrix yeah
there's probably a more official
definition out there that's just how i
would describe it no no it's a good
definition i get it
so what would you say was your red pill
moment what was the thing that broke the
camel's back was okay yeah i'm red pill
you know what's interesting
i i just was doing reaction videos i
started with rap reaction videos
and then somebody just sent me kevin
samuels
and i started like reacting to stuff i
called into a show um
i'm
i called a dude there's some other show
i called into too i forgot it was but
yeah i just started reacting to all the
content
and there's just a lot of stories where
i was like oh my god like i've seen that
um i didn't know if there was like a
necessarily like a red pill moment it
was just more
um the content was interesting i just
kept watching
you know what i always say that
my first introduction to the red pill
was also kevin samuels
so about two years ago
i was studying for exams at university
and
i think one this guy called the black
cargo on youtube just started speaking
about him i was like who is this guy he
keeps mentioning kevin samuel was like
who is this so then i started watching
him at that point i think he still had
but look under just above 100 000
subscribers at that point so it's still
relatively unknown in comparison to what
he became
and i just i realized a lot of the stuff
he said was actually very true and
helpful right exactly exactly especially
the stuff he said to men like you know
basically stop being a bum and
start living your life the way you want
it to be rather than just expecting
things to come your way especially for
the black community i think that's a
very important message but
it was something that i found to be
interesting at the very least
however okay i wouldn't call myself red
pill okay i wouldn't call myself red
bull because
i would say that
a lot of the stuff that red pool says
the red pool movement says is relatively
common sense yeah i would agree and
common sense isn't so common nowadays
very true very true depending on the
culture you're from i think that's very
true but a lot of the stuff they say
actually
is synonymous with things that you're
taught in african homes i've said to you
before i'm not read but i'm just
nigerian you know so it's like a lot of
stuff that like stuff like okay i
wouldn't personally want my wife to
aborted me because it just doesn't make
sense when it comes to
um you know having children and
the person having to take time off you
know it doesn't make sense for the
family people would say that's
misogynistic or whatever i think it's
just practical it doesn't make sense to
to be the
level earner in that sense i wouldn't
make her quit a job
but i'll work harder in order to earn
more than her
but then
i just i can't call myself red pool
because i think
a lot of the times when
it comes to red pool content
we fall into the same trap that we see
many of the radical feminists fall into
and so
when we did that a street interview and
the girl was saying oh all men are this
all men are that or men do this right
obviously it's not true obviously it's
just not something that makes sense
right
but then
we'll see a little red pool content say
basically
do the exact same thing with women
saying all women are like this all women
do this all women do that i've never
heard them say all i heard them say
modern women do this which is a very big
distinction so what would you say is the
distinction between more women and women
in general
um i would say modern women are women
that are chasing their careers over a
family
and
have bought into some of the lies of
feminism that's what i would call modern
woman but wouldn't you say that even
women who don't necessarily follow
careers so you know the ones who are
just instagram baddies quite quite
they're not executing queers but you
still call them modern women you could
say they're following a career they're
just not that good at it
i'm just bums
yeah but they're trying to they're
trying to like
they're following an instagram career
it's just not a successful one
i mean i think most women are modern
today
but like the point is women are
different today than they were in the
1950s it's it's a different breed of
women i don't think you're wrong but
then you think that the guys are also
very different yeah i agree
most most red pill channels would tell
you that too yeah like even even um
even fresh and fit they'll say men are
more feminine now than ever they are
yeah i will say that but to me it like
starts with the women
i will say because
as someone who watches a lot of
television in cinema
and you know i'd like to study it just
just for you know to improve my content
sometimes
i will say that the media is pushing a
certain image and narrative towards men
and i think that
you know
when we see an advert or on a tv show
there's always a bumbling idiot dad and
yes extremely conversant woman who has
to come in and save him from his
stupidity and i do think that's a very
bad message to be telling men because
you know
they're gonna they're meant to grow up
and help to propagate society but then
if you're making them weak [ __ ] yeah
what sort of society are we going to
live in unfortunately yeah with a bunch
of men that are afraid of a [ __ ]
why i don't get it
afraid of what a [ __ ]
you guys are like i need to call my wife
to do something i'm like you have to ask
your wife
what do you mean
i i get that and it's i think it's
that's why i would say that the red pool
movement is something that's extremely
necessary for society at the moment yeah
especially because you know when we have
such extreme
um you know on geared towards the other
side that's in very
far leftist feminists yeah you need
something to counteract that even even
when it's not feminist it's ingrained in
just like modern day like talking happy
wife happy life that's yeah that's a
phrase but what about his happiness no
one cares
i think that's a good segue into
dating and you know intersexual dynamics
what would you say is your opinion
current
date in base not your personal
experience but based on what you know
and what you've heard
um i would just say modern women are
side checks
in what sense like there's a small
percentage of guys [ __ ] all the girls
i mean sorry having sex with all that
[Laughter]
um and
yeah and it's like one out of three men
under 30 are virgins or haven't had sex
in the past year
and so 80 of women are sexually active
so who are they having sex with it's a
small percentage of the men they only
swipe right in dating apps like five
percent of the time it's all the same
guys so
uh yeah modern women are side chicks and
they're not getting into and like that's
why you see all these tick tocks of
girls hitting like 30 and they're saying
oh i've never been in a real
relationship well why because you're a
side chick
[Music]
that makes sense yeah that makes sense i
mean like how many girls has like drake
slept with i mean that's the extreme but
you know when you see the extreme you
see what's happening throughout society
right it how many girls does drake slept
with yeah future
i think my my issue with
when we say stuff like
modern women are side chicks and things
like that
my only issue with a statement like that
is the fact that
it doesn't account for the fact that
most women actually um even the new this
is stuff in the cdc in us
i think the average body count
woman in the us is four so um
it's actually not four it's around like
seven to eight
the last one that's the last one i've
seen yeah but um that that accounts all
women from like young age groups to old
grades
yeah so if you if you break it down
where it's um
like with just the younger age group
it's like 12
and that's that's average which means
half the people are at more than that
and i and as you know women lie about
their body counts of course of course
but i think and even just anecdotally
like when i ask i ask girls